now the latest on the war in Ukraine
where Rescuers are still sifting through
the rubble after one of Russia's
deadliest attacks on civilians in the
entire War One missile killed at least
30 people when it hit an apartment
building in the city of danipro on
Saturday Deborah petta has more from
Ukraine
this is what the aftermath of a war
declared largely on civilians looks like
another bloody weekend in Ukraine in one
brutal attack dozens killed many more
wounded the youngest victim just 15
years old
foreign
s were just waking up in this apartment
Block in denipro when Russia launched
two waves of missile strikes haunting
images of Rescuers working night and day
to find survivors pausing now and then
to listen
voices beneath the rubble like 23 year
old Anastasia schwetz who was in the
bathroom of her seventh floor apartment
when the Missile hit she's already lost
her husband on the front line now far
from the battlefield her home has been
taken to
and this young woman who was pulled from
the rubble still alive more than 18
hours after the attack as each child
passes the hope for finding survivors
gets dimmer but for the Russian defense
Ministry it was mission accomplished
saying their goals had been achieved
with the strike as missiles pounded
cities across the country the fighting
intensified in the contested towns of
solidar and bahut where Ukrainian
soldiers are defending themselves
against a Relentless onslaught of mostly
Wagner mercenaries recruited from
prisons across Russia
NATO's Secretary General has said that
more heavy weapons are headed for
Ukraine in the very near future for CBS
morning's Deborah pater harkiv